Hey everybody, it’s Aldis.
As an actor, host and advocate,
I’m blessed with the opportunity
to help tell amazing stories.
And on December 3rd, I’ll be
hosting a celebration of five new
incredible storytellers and their
award-winning screenplays.
The Academy Nicholl Fellowships
in Screenwriting has discovered
storytellers and championed
inclusive storytelling for 35 years.
On December 3rd, I’ll be joined
by fellow actors and leaders
in the motion picture industry
in a ceremony for the Nicholl’s
five new fellows for 2020.
With everything going on in
the world, their fierce and
unique stories are more timely,
more urgent than ever.
And that’s true for you as well.
Today, your story can be
more impactful than ever.
Your story can entertain
or educate or empower.
Your story can do all that.
And more.
Your story can change
the world.
Your story is everything.
So, tune in on December 3rd
to get involved and get inspired.
To learn more about the
Nicholl Fellowships story visit -
NichollFellowships.org
And, most importantly of all,
we can’t wait to hear yours.